bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi sur notre antenne les travaux
de la commission d' enquête sénatoriale
sur le dopage
cette semaine les sénateurs ont entendu
l' agence française de lutte contre le
dopage et notamment françoise à lanne
directrice des laboratoires d'analysé
qui a fait ce constat c'est le rugby qui
est le sport le plus touché par le
dopage
les sénateurs ont également entendu eux
jean françois lamour ancien ministre des
sports de 2002 à 2004 et c'est son
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite
merci à semis de nous avoir rejoints
c'est dans le cadre d'une commission
denquête certain nombre de formalisme
toutes formalités à remplir le public
n'étant pas très nombreux jeunes et pas
pour la c1 m'adresser à lui mais je dois
par contre vous demander de
prêté serment nous dit de nous dire la
vérité toute la vérité
en levant la main droite en 10 ans jure
je jure merci nous avons pour tradition
dans ces auditions de donner à la
personne qui est venu devant nous la
possibilité de s'exprimer comme elles le
souhaitent pendant un quart d'heure
vingt minutes plus ou moins en fonction
de ce qu'elle souhaite
et ensuite c'est le jeu traditionnel des
questions réponses qui se rend pour qui
seront posées soit par jean jacques
lozach le rapporteur soit par les
membres de notre commission denquête je
vous laisse donc la parole nous vous
écoutons avec attention
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs ne trompe pas
messieurs les et madame les sénateurs
je le crois que le titre de votre en
tout cas l'intitulé de votre commission
denquête et de faire un point sur
l'efficacité de la lutte antidopage et
en matière de lutte antidopage
quand on parle d'efficacité je crois
qu'il faut obligatoirement effectuer
dans un premier temps une comparaison
dans le temps que ce soit au niveau
national ou au niveau international et
vous me permettrez effectivement de
rapidement c'est de rappeler
effectivement où nous en étions il ya
encore on va dire une vingtaine d'années
et où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
tout d'abord au niveau de la france la
france a toujours été
quels que soient les gouvernements quels
que soient les ministres à la pointe en
matière de lutte antidopage
essentiellement en cela est dû à son
histoire en particulier le drame de
sipson 67 au mont ventoux
et puis évidemment on se souviendra plus
récemment de la sphère du tour de france
98 mais aussi de la faire cofidis en
2004 et d'autres sujets qui ne sont pas
liées directement à des sportifs
français mais je pense en particulier
aux championnats du monde d'athlétisme
en 2003 où on avait à ce moment là sous
une forme un peu décalé détectée
souvenez vous en la thg dans un c'est un
certain nombre de sportifs américains
donc la france a toujours été à la fois
au travers de la recherche
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir sur la
qualité du laboratoire national de
dépistage du dopage de châtenay malabry
mais également de son encadrement
législatif aux avant-postes en matière
de contrôle donc de recherche mais aussi
souvenez vous en travers de la loi 2006
au travers de l'installation du suivi
longitudinal qui est en quelque sorte
le l'outil embryonnaires qui a débouché
sur le passeport biologique
certes suivi longitudinal était dans un
premier temps un outil de préservation
de la santé le passeport est maintenant
lui un outil entre guillemets qui peut
être également répressif mais est il en
était en tout cas les le cadre général
et on le voit au travers de l'évolution
cela allait dans le bon sens la france a
également toujours été aux avant postes
en créant le cpl des qui s'est ensuite
transformée en af elle d une entité
juridique indépendante
répondant mieux vous en conviendrez aux
préconisations mise en place après la
rédaction du premier code mondial
antidopage ans en 2000 en 2003 et puis
la france a ôté ac a aussi été
précurseur en matière de localisation
des athlètes puisque moi-même en tant qu
ancien athlète membre de l'équipe de
france olympique des jeux de barcelone
j'ai été dans l'obligation de remplir un
formulaire de localisation 92
j'étais très énervé de leur empire mais
en 92 déjà j'avais à remplir ce document
qui permettait dans des conditions
évidemment vous en doutez assez
aléatoire de préciser dans quels
endroits nous trouvions dans le cas de
la préparation finale des jeux de
barcelone
c'est en quelque sorte a aussi un outil
précurseur de ce qui existe aujourd'hui
qui est beaucoup plus contraignant qui
s'appelle le dispositif adams
comparaison évolution également je le
disais tout à l'heure au niveau
international et on peut le dire il ya
un avant et un après 98 à l'évidence
avant 98
nous avions connu c'est peut-être
l'exemple le plus frappant la sphère ben
johnson aux jeux de séoul
il aura fallu je sais pas si vous en
souvenez toute la persuasion du prince
de mérode à l'époque
le directeur du service médical du seuil
haut pour que j'en suis intimement
convaincu cette affaire sorte
il aura fallu effectivement que le
prince de mérode qui n'en pouvait plus
un certain nombre de cas qui étaient
plus ou moins cachés tape du poing sur
la table en plein jeux de séoul pour que
la sphère ben johnson sorte avec tout ce
que ça comporte aux en souvenez d'image
en voyant ben johnson quitté
précipitamment séoul
mais pour autant entre 88 et 98 peut
vraiment d'effort en matière de
cohérence et en matière de priorités en
matière de lutte antidopage parle
essentiellement du côté du mouvement
sportif mais également du côté d'un
certain nombre de pays qui en avait fait
un outil de promotion au travers du
rayonnement de leurs sportifs
je peins citer les pays en question en
tout cas il était de notoriété publique
que ces pays utilisait le sport comme
vecteur de promotion mais également le
de pages pour que leurs athlètes se
trouve parmi les meilleurs lapret 98
c'est très clairement j'ai bien le
rattrapage du temps perdu avec très
rapidement un colloque en garnison en
organisant 99 à lausanne où madame marie
george buffet a tenu un rôle important
puisque elle avait été au premier aux
premières loges dans la sphère du tour
de france 98 et lausanne 99 débouchant
vous le savez sur deux objectifs
principaux la création de l' agence
mondiale antidopage pour la première
fois pour la première fois mouvement
sportif et gouvernements travaillaient
ensemble ensemble à la mise en place
d'un programme mondial antidopage
le finançaient ensemble à parts égales
également ce qui était une grande
nouveauté puisque lama dispose d'un
budget d'environ 21 22 millions de
dollars donc le finance est quasiment à
parts égales avec une répartition en
fonction d'eux
des différents donateurs choc la france
et de l'ordre maman de sept cent mille
euros je crois annuel et puis le
deuxième volet la deuxième priorité
était la rédaction du code mondial
antidopage qui finalement est l
émanation de cette mise en cohérence et
de ce travail en commun et un code
mondial antidopage qui est allé très
vite finalement à rédiger et à être
adoptée au moins sur son principe
puisqu'en 2003 à madrid nous validions
le contenu de ce code
le code il avait comme principale
qualité d'essayer de trouver c'est là où
la notion de relations internationales
est très forte et elle est indissociable
de la lutte antidopage
une sorte de consensus sur à la fois la
liste des produits détectés hors et en
compétition est une sorte de hyères
archi des sanctions font en fonction des
produits trouvés ainsi qu'également un
certain nombre de procédures de contrôle
tant en matière de contrôle en
compétition que deux compos contrôle
hors compétition et ça c'est je crois la
principale avancée est véritablement je
crois le l'avènement d'une réelle
organisation de la lutte antidopage
mondiale sont est suivi le code 2007
dont une version 2 qui a amélioré
sensiblement en particulier en
augmentant sensiblement le niveau des
sanctions mais également et nous avons
malheureusement connu
en son temps un sujet qu'on aurait bien
aimé voir être traité par le code
version 2 qui est la rétroactivité des
contrôles antidopages rétroactivité
allant jusqu'à huit ans c'est à dire
être en capacité de trouver des produits
huit ans après grâce à l'amélioration
technique de détection
le quart atypique étant effectivement le
travail remarquable effectué par
châtenay malabry et le docteur de ses
hauts risques qui auraient effectivement
pu re contrôler les flux les flacons du
rin et suce traduire in du tour de
france cadeau à 80,18 pas simplement
pour en faire une epide une étude
épidémiologique mais également pour
fournir un certain nombre d'éléments
donc est positif en matière de dopage à
l' agence mondiale antidopage
donc on le voit beaucoup de retard
jusqu'à 98 et il faut bien le dire même
si tout cela est encore évidemment un
parfait est par nature évolutif un
beaucoup de progrès en une période
extrêmement courte quand on part du
principe que ce code est cette agence
mondiale sont traitées au niveau de
relations internationales on imagine que
ça représente y compris d'ailleurs les
efforts pour nous législateurs français
quand il nous faut avec une forme de
contorsions il faut bien dire accepter
un texte émanant d'une structure de
droit suisse basée à montréal
il faut donc que nous ayons une
véritable volonté au travers le serbe de
la convention de l'unesco je le
reconnais bien volontiers mais il aura
fallu effectivement accepté ces
principes finalement perdre une part de
nos compétences et de notre souveraineté
mais encore une fois au profit d'une
meilleure une lutte antidopage largement
améliorée en matière d'efficacité mais
par nature aussi ces tags sont évolutifs
donc là où les uns et les autres nous ce
soit au sénat ou à l'assemblée avons en
permanence améliorer ce texte quoique
dans ce domaine là les droits d'auteur
doivent être mis de côté l'humidité du
rédacteur et du législateur également
parce que par nature ces textes sont
évolutifs et je le dis pour la lutte
antidopage comme je le dirai pour la
lutte contre les paris illégaux par
nature parce que là aussi on est du
niveau international et que internet par
nature est extrêmement volatil et
évolutif et qu'il nous faut en
permanence être en capacité de faire
évoluer évoluer ses textes deuxième
réflexion je vois si je suis trop long
de sur le président deuxième réflexion
je voudrais parler d'évolution il ya
cinq évolutions majeures qui sont devant
nous et qu'il nous faut en permanence
appréhender c'est la première
l'universalité du sport de nouvelles
nations arrive dans le concert
international avec des cultures qui sont
par nature différente en matière
d'appréciation de la lutte antidopage et
moyens également différent des pays
comme l'afrique sur le continent
africain qui se foutent royalement de
mettre en place un programme de lutte
anti dopage parce qu'ils ont à peine de
quoi chausser leurs sportifs à peine de
quoi les faire vivre
à peine de quoi les entraîner donc vous
imaginez bien quand on leur demande de
mettre en place un programme de lutte
antidopage c'est le cadet de leurs
soucis c'est pas de la mauvaise volonté
de leur part et c'est un cas des deux
c'est le cadet de leurs soucis une aussi
de nouvelles disciplines des disciplines
en particulier dans les sports que je
qualifierais d'un peu plus fun où on le
voit bien toute hiérarchie toute règle
est extrêmement difficile à faire
appliquer sur tous les continents
et là aussi il ya un effort de pédagogie
un effort je vous sens si un exemple
peut-être le golf redevient discipline
olympique le golfe
c'est toujours très clairement non pas
mis de côté mais a toujours considéré
que la lutte antidopage n'était pas une
de ses priorités or aujourd'hui ils sont
puisqu'il son programme un nouveau
programme olympique dans l'obligation de
mettre en place un programme antidopage
qui sera appliqué de la manière la plus
stricte pendant les éliminatoires pour
déterminer des ce champion qui
participeront aux jeux de rio de janeiro
évidemment pendant la compétition
les pratiques aussi deuxième élément les
pratiques également ont évolué avec une
amélioration de la performance
comment traiter par exemple les caissons
hyperbares en savez ces questions qui
permettent de reproduire un entraînement
en altitude ou en tout cas une présence
en altitude et qui à un moment donné on
était à la fois critiquer et quelquefois
même interdit mais également comment
traiter le cas pistorius avec une
amélioration qu'on peut considérer comme
bionique donc là aussi nous devons nous
législateurs mais pas simplement nous en
france mais à la fois en relation avec
le mouvement sportif et partout dans le
monde
imaginez ce que peuvent être ces
évolutions
toujours dans le domaine de la recherche
ou savez très bien on est loin
maintenant du simple massage pour
récupérer une séance d'entraînement ou
d'un lendemain d'une compétition
particulièrement éprouvante
on a maintenant des systèmes de
récupération par cryothérapie par
balnéothérapie mais également par
perfusion qu'il nous faut également
prendre en compte quand on doit
déterminer le cadre légal ou illégal de
ce qu'est une un accompagnement à
l'amélioration de la performance et le
dopage lui-même troisième volet dans ces
méthodes a largement évolué on est passé
du prodej au dopage sanguin est
maintenant au dopage génétique il nous
faut absolument être en face finalement
avec ces améliorations ou souvenez du
cas de l'allemagne de l'est qui mettait
enceinte seat est féminine dans les deux
trois semaines qui succédait au fait
qu'elle était effectivement enceinte
alors elles avaient des performances
améliorées et cela a fait partie de la
panoplie en matière de dopage entre
guillemets en tout cas d'amélioration de
la performance
on se met en place à l'époque en
allemagne de l'est ont dit d'autres pays
mais en particulier en allemagne de
l'est
quatrième volet d'évolution la
circulation des athlètes
là où il était assez facilement
repérables circule maintenant dans tous
les pays du monde
pas simplement pour les compétitions
mais également pour les phases
d'entraînement ou souviens d'un certain
nombre de lieux d'entraînement assez
symbolique je parlais d'entraînement au
maroc l'entraînement en afrique du sud
entraînement dans d'autres pays où là
aussi il ne faut pas par nature et par
définition être suspecté d'être en
situation de subir des traitements à
base de dopage mais en tout cas il faut
être en capacité de suivre l'athlète et
c'est en cela que le dispositif
adams qui est extrêmement contraignant
extrêmement contraignant a été mis en
place
et quand on parle de circulation des
sportives ne soit pas également oublier
la circulation des produits dopants
je crois que là aussi europol et
interpol doivent prendre en compte de
manière beaucoup plus précise cette
dimension de l'utilisation en
particulier internet pour commander des
produits interdits dans un certain
nombre de régions du monde et les faire
livrer à quelques mètres de votre
domicile ou de votre lieu d'entraînement
dernier volet c'est celui de l'argent
dans le sport est ce qu'il faut craindre
effectivement que l'afflux d'argent
encourage de dopage
je suis plus mesuré je suis plus mesuré
dans cet aspect des choses que je crois
ça a été un des sujets que vous avez
abordé lors des précédentes auditions je
me permets d'y répondre dès maintenant
je vous donnerai peut-être un exemple
d2d 1907 le vidal qui était le
dictionnaire médical qui en était à sa
2e ou 3e édition faisait référence à un
produit à base de strychnine et il était
indiqué en matière de destination de ce
produit bon pour les cyclistes dont vous
le voyez ce n'était pas déjà un problème
de d'argent c'était en tout cas un
problème de culture plus que là il faut
reconnaître que plus il ya d'argent
plus il ya de sophistication du dopage
ça c'est une évidence et c'est cet
élément là qu'il faut prendre en compte
mais est ce que l'argent influe sur la
propension à se doper je ne pense pas je
crois que ce qui influe le sportif s'est
quelquefois la recherche d'une pré forme
d'une performance à outrance ou alors le
retour à la compétition le plus
rapidement possible après un coup de
moins bien ou une blessure importante
c'est là où effectivement il faut et je
viendrai tout à l'heure que le sport
qu'ils soient absolument bien encadré
quelles sont les perspectives pour
conclure monsieur le président je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un problème en
matière de contrôle antidopage je
regardais les derniers chiffres en tout
cas ceux qui sont consultables de la fld
sur à peu près dix mille contrôle je
crois qu'il ya 200 cas positifs nous ne
pouvons pas nous satisfaire de ce ratio
non pas qu'ils expriment une qualité de
la lutte antidopage en france et de la
protection du sportif mais se tient coût
qui est important et je crois qu'il faut
aller je lui ai dit tout à l'heure vers
un ciblage beaucoup plus performants
donc des publics si beaucoup plus
choisi beaucoup mieux choisi des
sportifs à contrôler et surtout
progressivement une substitution des
contrôles hors compétition par le
passeport biologique qui me semble être
aujourd'hui le meilleur outil de
contrôle sur le long terme d'un sportif
je vous rappelle que il permet de
veiller à ce que lorsqu un paramètre est
perturbé qu'ils soient physiologique ou
biologique
alors effectivement le médecin mais
également l'autorité de contrôle peut
suspecter soit une situation de
faiblesse de l'athlète ou ne suspectait
une prise de produits ou en tout cas un
procédé en matière de dopage pour
améliorer ou perturber un certain nombre
de performances et on ne peut évidemment
pas dissocier le passeport biologique du
dispositif
adams même si celui là et je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure extrêmement contraignant
autre sujet sur lequel il faut être
extrêmement vigilant et là je crois que
législateur mais également des autorités
publiques ont leur rôle à jouer
c'est la maîtrise dea ut est d'aider eu
lorsque j'étais encore vice-président de
l'agencement des recteurs ans qu'il doit
pas je me suis battu avec le soutien d'
ailleurs des experts français du
laboratoire de châtenay pour que par
exemple les glucocorticoïdes soient
considérés comme des produits dopants
je m'aperçois effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui les glucocorticoïdes sont
acceptés grâce à des à ut donc je crois
qu'il faut être extrêmement vigilant
effectivement à ne pas voir un certain
nombre de produits autorisés et qu'on en
arrive finalement à une certains
souhaitent d'ailleurs un dopage
médicalisé cédé 1 2 pages sous contrôle
médical
je crois que là dans ce domaine là il
faut être extrêmement ferme
c'est évidemment pas du sujet du
législateur directement mais en tout cas
le justicier tort quand il s'adresse au
ministre ce ministre ayant la capacité
d'intervenir auprès de l' agence
mondiale antidopage et c'est espère doit
être extrêmement vigilant à
l'encadrement extrêmement strict des iut
et des débuts ensuite je crois que l'
agence mondiale antidopage doit être
l'outil de coordination en matière de
recherche c'est à dire qu'il doit
mutualiser les moyens parce que je
voulais dit le danger du dopage
génétique est l'un des dangers les plus
évidents qui nous attend et c'est à la
chance mondiale antidopage a été initié
au travers de ses fonds propres mais
également au travers de la mise en
réseau des laboratoires de recherche
ce type de recherche je les lis tout à
l'heure également renforcer la lutte en
matière de trafic de produits dopants
il faut bien dire en dehors du de
quelques comme on va dire étincelles
mais pas plus
d'interpol peu de trafic ont été mises à
jour peut alors je reconnais qu'interpol
est aujourd'hui focalisée sur la lutte
antiterroriste sur un salon de trafic en
particulier le trafic de drogue mais il
me semble important là aussi d'insister
à ce que ces entités internationales
travaillent de façon beaucoup plus
évidente est forte en matière de lutte
antidopage et deux sur les trafics de
produits dopants dernier élément
toujours et encore mais dans ce domaine
on peut dire que nous sommes performants
mais fait toujours veillé à ce que nous
soyons plus encore continuer à
travailler au niveau de la prévention au
niveau de l'éducation de nos de nos
jeunes en particulier pour que les
éducateurs sportifs quels que soient
leur formation que cette formation
évolue d'un d'un répertoire national des
formations au niveau du ministère des
sports vers un répertoire de l'éducation
nationale soient toujours aussi
performant en matière d'éducation et de
pédagogie en matière de lutte antidopage
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre
cet exposé complet c'est l'heure des
questions
le premier à vous interroger sera notre
rapporteur jean jacques lozach bien
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre remercie de votre contribution
notre commission d' enquête
parlementaire vous avez bien compris
dans quel état d'esprit on appréhender
cette commission avant d'être encore
plus efficace dans cette lutte contre le
dopage et l'iut lesquels vous avez je
dirais à porter très largement votre
contribution puisque on peut même dire
qu'une loi porte votre nom
la loi de la loi de tout choix du mode
précisément sur 7 sur cette loi de 2006
aujourd'hui sept ans plus tard quel est
le bilan l'évaluation le regard
rétrospectif que vous portez sur ce
texte législatif est ce qu'il ya par
exemple des des domaines dans lesquels
vous dites est bien là j'aurais dû aller
plus loin et c'est bien une
à l'évidence oui et je reconnais que
c'est c'est tout à fait normal que nous
posions ces questions là et que son
palais de critiques on on imagine
toujours le meilleur pour un dispositif
législatif avec une seule contrainte que
c'est qu'ils puissent être applicable et
qu'il soit toujours en cohérence avec ce
qui se passe en dehors nos frontières
parce que par nature le sportif je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure bouge et que
les compétitions sportives se déroule
sur l'ensemble l'ensemble des continents
les quels sont les points forts de
de la loi 2006 je crois que c'est le
fait que l'autorité des ça pouvait la
fld devienne une autorité indépendante
et cela c'était indispensable dans
l'application du code ça c'était le
principal la principale raison de la
rédaction de la loi 2006 c'est
l'application du code
on est en pleine cohérence avec les
préconisations du code mondial est en
gros on prépare l'atterrissage du code
mondial antidopage au travers de la
convention de l'unesco sur le sol
français
donc il nous fallait être
particulièrement en phase avec le
dispositif qui nécessitait un
représentant entre guillemets même si
c'est pas tout à fait le cas mais c'est
un peu l'esprit
un représentant de l' agence mondiale
antidopage sur le sol français de
manière indépendante c'est-à-dire que
l'agencé est en capacité de répondre
directement aux sollicitations de l'
agence mondiale antidopage
l'autre l'autre volet sur lequel je suis
peut-être le plus content d'avoir mis en
place et le suivi longitudinal dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure qui était un
peu le précurseur du coût du passeport
biologique avec un élément qui
n'existaient pas précédemment il y avait
des contrôles s'il existait je suis pas
parti d'une feuille blanche
il y avait pour les athlètes de haut
niveau les plus performants des visites
médicales fréquence 2 3 2 3 visites par
parents mais qui finalement était liée
au bon vouloir des fédérations et
surtout au moyen des fédérations
sportives
là nous l'avons imposé à toutes les
fédérations y compris en leur
fournissant les moyens nécessaires avec
un volet qui n'existaient pas
précédemment qui était le volet
psychologique et en particulier parce
que nous étions rendus compte que le
sportif commencé à se doper
quand il était en grande difficulté
difficultés psychiques c'est à dire
quand il avait des baisses de résultats
quand il avait
quand il avait une blessure extrêmement
lourdes et qu' il se trouvait sous la
pression à la fois du retour en équipe
dans des temps extrêmement contraint et
c'est là on s'en rend des comptes c'est
là effectivement dans les baisses de
régime où ils étaient susceptibles
effectivement d'utiliser des produits
dopants et surtout nous étions trop
également aperçu d'autres choses c'est
que parler un psychologue est quelque
chose qui n'est pas naturel en tout cas
c'est pas quelque chose que le sportif
de haut niveau fait naturellement parce
qu'il a toujours le sentiment d'être en
situation de faiblesse et là où il doit
lui parler dans ces périodes où adultes
ou en tout cas approchant de l'âge
adulte
il devrait le faire il n'avait pas
l'habitude et le fait que dès 13 ans dès
14 ans il est l'habitude une fois par an
d'avoir un contact avec un psychologue
nous sentait nous permettait de penser
que ensuite cette habitude prise il
aurait plus facilement ensuite accès à
lui en cas de en cas de grande en cas de
grandes difficultés
est ce que est ce qu'on n'est pas était
ne pas aller assez loin sur d'autres
volets il ya un sujet sur lequel
vraiment on a réfléchi mais encore une
fois comme on voulait être nickel en
phase parfaite avec le code mondial
on n'a pas voulu faire les italiens
l'ont fait nous on a résisté
c'était le fait de pénaliser la prise de
produits dopants c'est à dire de faire
en sorte que le sportif ne soit plus une
victime est un un acteur du dopage et
donc qu'il soit répréhensible comme
l'ont fait les italiens alors les
italiens avaient pris un temps d'avancé
que je crois que la loi avait été votée
un an un an et demi avant la nôtre on
avait regardé quel était le résultat
le seul résultat progrès était celui de
panzani le pauvre il a disparu depuis
mais il faut savoir que pantani n'a
jamais été condamné par la justice
italienne
il est passé devant le tribunal mais il
n'a jamais purgé une quelconque
plaignent jamais été condamné donc
finalement on s'est rangé plutôt à la
position du mouvement sportif qui était
dire le de père est une victime et c'est
son entourage qui effectivement
est pénalement responsable et doit subir
au delà de la sanction sportive bien sûr
une sanction une sanction pénale
est ce que on peut redonner la parole
aux rapporteurs parce qu'il n'avait pas
tout à fait terminée tout à l'heure et
je les coupe et non à ben on commence à
répondre
donc il va reprendre désole la remise en
forme de questions complémentaires
ministre van avant d'être un homme
politique vous avez été un sportif et
sportive de haut niveau
champion du monde champion olympique est
ce que justement pendant ses années de
pratique là vous avez été confronté pris
connaissance à l'intérieur de votre
sport l'escrim de pratiques dopantes ou
est-ce que vous pensez que ce sport l'a
fait partie des sports protéger ou
épargné et puis la deuxième question
vous avez beaucoup parlé de l'ama et
vous avez notamment rappelé qu un
certain moment vous étiez vice-président
de cette agence mondiale antidopage
or un moment vous avez déposé votre
candidature pour être président puis
vous l'avait retiré est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner des indications sur
les raisons de cette marche arrière
alors sur la première question aucun
sport on est à l'abri
aucun l'escrim l'est peut-être un peu
plus que d'autres
pour une raison simple c'est que la
technique est largement supérieur enfin
l'aspect technique est largement
supérieur à l'aspect physique et vous
vous voyez d'ailleurs dans beaucoup
d'autres sports quand l'aspect physique
est prépondérant alors en tout cas sur
le dopage tel que nous le connaissons
aujourd'hui qui je vous le rappelle ou
améliore l'endurance c'est le cas de le
paix aux eaux et améliore la force et
kada testostérone 1 pour faire court où
les corticoïdes pour élever le seuil de
supportabilité de l'effort répéter bon
ce que c'est pas le cas de l'escrim
c'est pâques halloween ce que la force
physique en escrime
elle est nécessaire sur l'explosion du
geste mais pas sur la force au sens où
il faut porter un
une charge de manière répétée le seul
cas que je subis aucune pression pour
prendre un produit dopant premièrement
deuxièmement le seul cas plus ou moins
avérées est liée aux alors je parle pas
des histoires de prise de gouttes
nasales ou de la corée ming lui cause ça
c'est des copains
je considère ça comme des bêtises
voiliers mais pas comme un dopage
organisé pour faire la part des choses
le seul cas de dopage organisé mais qui
n'a pas été réellement trouvé c'est
celui de death primeur allemands de
l'est qui dans les années 80 début des
années 80 83 84 sont d'un seul coup
devenus excellents
il voyait tout il voyait où on allait ne
voyait pas où ils allaient reparle dans
les gestes et ils ont été attrapés à
l'atropine qui était donc un produit qui
est améliorée en tout cas qu'ils avaient
des facultés je suis pas médecin mais
qui avait une faculté d'améliorer
l'acuité visuelle est apparue vraiment
où ils ont été repérés ils ont
immédiatement disparu de la circulation
c'est le seul cas réels où il ya eu une
vraie suspicion matière d'organisation
d'un dispositif de dopage mais pour le
reste je voulais dia pas ya pas eu de
cas flagrant en tout cas de d'éléments
qui nous permettent de dire qu'il y a eu
comme dans d'autres sports la natation
l'athlétisme d une organisation permet
pas d'utiliser une organisation en
matière de en matière de dopage dans un
pays où dans une équipe
quant à mon aventure à m'a effectivement
un jour ajout rappelle la citation à
l'époque dick pound est là était
jusqu'en 2007 le président de l'agencé
antidopage et 2 par l'alternance de la
présidence il avait commencé en 2001 il
concluait sa présidence en 2007 et il
avait été prévu puisque le financement
était à parts égales que ce soit un
représentant des gouvernements qui soit
président pour six ans enfin trois ans
renouvelable une fois et j'avais donc
été choisi pour être vice président de
l' agence mondiale antidopage
la vice présidence enclenchant
automatiquement en tout cas l'arrivée à
la présidence une fois que ding par nav
est arrivé et je vous rappelle qu'elle
soit en a je venais d'être élu député
que l'agent sommet mondial antidopage
est basée à montréal
et moi j'avais vu j'étais parti du
principe que je serai président de
l'amac s'il y avait un consensus général
autour de ma candidature qui avait été
actée par la quasi-totalité des
protagonistes côté gouvernement et il
s'est trouvé que je le dis très
clairement le monde anglo saxon a
souhaité présenter un candidat contre
moi il ya une sorte de cabale alors vous
pouvez toujours me dire mais là pourquoi
vous n'avez pas été au bout moi je
partais du principe encore une fois que
la lutte antidopage est un monde
extrêmement violent et dur pour ceux qui
en ont la responsabilité
non j'ai je suis partie des ligues du
principe que pour être efficace il
fallait qu'il y ait un consensus sur mon
nom enfin quel que soit le nom partir du
moment où je me retrouvais avec un
certain nombre de pays anglo saxons qui
ont une vision différente de la mine de
la nôtre lutte antidopage avec un
opposant j'estimais que je ne pourrais
pas
être en mesure d'appliquer correctement
un programme efficace de lutte
antidopage
il faut il suffit de regarder
aujourd'hui on l agence mondiale
antidopage
ce que représente l'actuel président de
l'ama pour se rendre compte que j'avais
raison effectivement de m'inquiéter
en ce qui concerne le poids aujourd'hui
de l' agence mondiale antidopage dans le
concert international
merci est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
sur le rapporteur ou premier les
collègues
monsieur dufaut puis monsieur mother
merci président oui rapidement est bien
évident que le ce qu'a dit le ministre
est vrai la lutte antidopage son labo
efficace au niveau législatif
elle passe par des textes évolutif
permanent il faut pas s'arrêter c'est
l'oubli tellement vite
bon c'est vrai qu'il ya pas le droit
d'auteur mais je voudrais témoigner
comme l'a fait le nôtre à porter tout à
l'heure sur l'étape décisive qu'on a
vécu un petit peu comme un mois
modestement discuter simplement reportés
au sénat dans la rade 2006 mais c'est
vrai que vous avez donné une impulsion
décisive et la mise en place de la salle
des nouvelles formules
on doit beaucoup monsieur le ministre il
faut le dire
alors nous avons auditionné depuis
quelques temps pas mal de responsables
de la fédé anciens et actuels et à une
idée qui semble faire l'unanimité c'est
d'essayer de dissocier pour rendre
beaucoup plus efficace la lutte
antidopage le volet qui relève
uniquement du contrôle recherche labo
d'une part et puis le voulait à part les
pressions et sanctions
quel est votre avis sur cette
éventualité venir tout dépend la
personnalité qui dirige la fld
quand j'ai pris et nous l'avons fait de
concert puisque c'est une discussion et
un débat que nous avons eu dans l'ici au
sénat extrêmement riche
scherer du faux mais nous n'avons
également à l'assemblée nationale je
partais du principe que pour être
performant et pour être reconnu au
niveau national et international
il fallait que la fld puisse rayonner
c'est-à-dire et soit en capacité de
montrer notre notre force dans le
domaine de la lutte antidopage et de la
recherche
c'est pour ça que je souhaitais associer
les deux entités je les fais également
parce que je trouve que l' effet le des
seuls est un organisme que je
qualifierais à ce moment-là de
statutaire mais pas de dynamique dans la
lutte antidopage par nature elle doit
être dynamique elle doit être en
perpétuel mouvement et je vous donnerai
un exemple et je le regrette d'ailleurs
que présidents successifs de la fédé ne
l'ait pas fait j'avais proposé je crois
d'ailleurs que je l'avais dit à
l'occasion des débats
en tout cas je l'avais dit au président
de la fld quand je les avais rencontrés
il me semblait important que l'aide que
le chef des maladies puissent aller
conquérir des parts de marché dans la
lutte dans le contrôle antidopage comme
le font d'autres laboratoires
je pense en particulier au laboratoire
de montréal
le tout récent laboratoire de doha par
exemple ils vont chercher des parts de
marché en matière de contrôle il
s'appuie sur une des contrôles
performant mais il finance également en
partie grâce à leurs recherches et pour
moi cette entité me paraissait
indispensable à créer j'irai même plus
loin aujourd'hui puisque vous m'entendez
la perche je la saisis je pense
aujourd'hui que pour être encore plus
performant
il faudrait rassembler toutes les
autorités en france qui peu ou prou
préserve l'éthique du sport et je pense
en particulier à un rapprochement sous
une forme qui reste à définir mais je
pense que le modèle de l'arjel me semble
être un modèle pertinent et performant
rapprocher l'arjel et la fld ça me
semble être à la fois en matière de
maîtrise des coûts tout cela cottin on
ne remet pas en question principe de
coûts mais tout cela coûte aux largeur
en matière d'argent public donc coûte
aux contribuables coûte à la france et
le fait de réunir l'arjel et la fld sous
une même entité avec ce même principe de
protection de la pratique sportive me
semble être pertinents rien n'est pire
que l'immobilisme en matière de lutte
antidopage et la fld seul me semble
aujourd'hui être une un mauvais choix en
matière de dynamique en matière de
recherche en matière de rayonnement
je comprends l'idée 1 qu'il y a de dire
il ya un aspect juridique il faut
absolument préserver et puis les sons de
laboratoire peut-être est adossé à un
réseau universitaire pourquoi pas mais
je trouve que en tout cas dans notre
dispositif français cela a du sens et
cela doit continuer comme ça stéphane
mazars oui merci monsieur présent
l'ancien ministre
vous avez vous avez indiqué notamment en
parlant de votre expérience
professionnelle que c'était parfois
pesant de se soumettre aux contrôles
notamment contrôles inopinés et c est
que ça pouvait être une atteinte aux
libertés individuelles et c'est vrai
qu'on sent qu'il ya un débat est entre
entre la lutte antidopage et la liberté
individuelle des sportifs que ce soit
donc cette obligation de dire presque au
jour le jour où on est ou même
d'ailleurs de se soumettre à un suivi
médical avec un passeport etc
quel est votre sentiment aujourd'hui est
ce qu on a trouvé un bon point
d'équilibré justement entre la nécessité
de lutter contre le dopage et ses
libertés individuelles qui sont quand
même essentiel parce que quand on
accepte d'être sportif l'acceptent pas
forcément de rogner sur sa liberté un
chien
donc ça c'est le premier point et puis
le second point vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure quand vous avez fait le bilan de
votre votre loi l'hésitation que vous
aviez eu donc à 5 sonné le sportif
lui-même est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pensez la même source étant précisé que
ce qui est dit qui peut être entendu
c'est que la sanction sportive et divers
très lourde pour le sportif quand il est
suspendu pendant plusieurs années quand
il est déchu de ses titres c'est déjà
donc assez assez affligeant mais quand
on voit aujourd'hui les yeux quand on
voit les avantages que peuvent
aujourd'hui retiré d'une carrière
sportive donc certains de nos
compatriotes est ce qu'il faut pas aller
plus loin
est-ce qu'il faut pas aujourd'hui quand
même passé la vitesse supérieure
parce que ça a un effet dissuasif et
puis je crois quand même que quand on
voit les enjeux que ça représente
aujourd'hui le sport quand on voit les
moyens qu'on y met les moyens notamment
komeda les moyens de prévention ou
d'investigation ou de répression du
dopage est ce qu'il faut pas aller
jusqu'à la sanction des sportifs même 3
qui serait comme un signal assez fort
que pourrait donner la société
alors oui merci sur le sur la
localisation
c'est un mal nécessaire c'est un mal
nécessaire
et je pense qu'il ya la localisation est
encore mieux comprises quand on
l'associé au passeport biologique c'est
pour moi indissociables et indices ou
indispensable quel quoi qu'il en coûte
aux sportifs de haut niveau même si la
pilule encore une fois c'est qu'elle ne
dirait est difficile à avaler
peut-être à terme si le passeport
biologique démontre toute son efficacité
alors il ne sera plus nécessaire d'aller
contrôler un sportif de manière inopinée
là où il se trouve peut-être mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui
et à mon avis pour le cours moyen terme
je crois que les deux sont
indissociables et est véritablement il
faut que des athètes continue à subir
ces deux types de contrôles la sanction
le danger c'est le décalage entre la
sanction sportive et de la sanction
pénale qui nous amènerait dans un
imbroglio en matière d'application de la
sanction la justice pénale et elle peut
avoir différents types de vitesse en
fonction du pays et on est loin je pense
d'une cohérence en matière de procédure
pénale ou civile non l'ensemble des pays
du monde et sur l'ensemble des
continents par nature remettrait en
cause
on pourrait remettre en cause la
sanction sportive qui l a à peu près
maintenant établi un schéma est une
procédure à peu près respectées
quand on commence avec en première
instance et qu'on peut terminer au tass
on est en gros on est en gros sur une
période d'un an
allez on va dire une petite année sion
en cas de plan disent par exemple
landis a été chopé au tour de france
2006 il je reviendrai peut-être sur le
sujet si vous me posez la question ce
que j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des
interprétations différentes
à l'occasion de vos auditions il n'a pas
pu faire le tour de france 2007 il a été
banni du tour de france 2007 dans un an
pensez vous vraiment que la justice
civile puisse effectivement en un an
traiter le problème avec ce que ça
comporte d'appel
et différents types de recours je ne le
pense pas et donc rien de pire
finalement que la justice civile
remettent en question une décision de
justice sportive au prétexte que le
rythme n'est pas le même donc en mon for
intérieur je pense que vous avez raison
d'imaginer effectivement d'appliquer
comme l'ont fait les italiens ce
dispositif parallèle mais je pense que
en matière d'efficacité quand on sait
qu'un sportif peut être suspendu
maintenant quatre ans voire quelquefois
même c'est rare mais avis je crois qu'il
ya un choix qu'il faut préserver c'est
celui effectivement de la sanction
sportive quitte effectivement que un
certain nombre d'intervenants en
particulier les sponsors pourquoi pas
même l'état on l'a vu avec le cam song à
ce moment-là porte la faire devant les
tribunaux au prétexte qu'il ya eu
tricherie et il ya eu surtout versement
en tout cas perception de deux sommes
indues en matière de sponsoring pourquoi
pas ça c'est les lacs les conséquences
d'une sanction sportive et nunes d'une
décision effectivement qui a été validé
par le code mondial antidopage
donc oui sur le principe mais non
malheureusement dans l'application et
dans les fêtes
donc si on pénale ne s'adresserait pas
nécessairement aux sportifs convaincus
de nos bases ça pourrait aussi porter
c'est là peut-être il faut plus
expliquer les choses selon nous sur le
fait que quelqu'un qui est au courant
l'affairé de dopage qui a même contribué
montre telle aide
tel est l action qui refuse de dire ce
qu'il sait qui refuse de désigner les
responsables de l'opération de dommage
pour elle à être pénalement sanctionné
pas nécessairement celui s'est fait
coincer doper sa le dealer en quelque
sorte il est déjà sanctionné par la loi
c'est notre loi on sait déjà le quart
c'est déjà le cas il est déjà pour
simplement incitation au trafic de
produits dopants
là vous parlez effectivement d'un autre
cas c'est celui de long
orages du sportif qui effectivement
garde le silence est-ce que ce alors
peut-être faut-il effectivement dans ce
domaine à améliorer effectivement le
dispositif législatif faut qu' ils
soient concernés pour maintenant
effectivement un certain nombre de
diffusions d'informations qu'il détient
mais encore faut-il pouvoir le prouver
et on ne pourra le prouver qu'à
posteriori on ne pourra le prouver qu'un
pisteur oeil
mais pourquoi pas ça ça peut être une
une évolution législative mais vous en
conviendrez ne peut arriver qu'à
festoyer puisque ça veut donc dire que
c'est le sportif lui-même qui livre les
noms à l'occasion effectivement d'un
d'une procédure de sanction sportive et
qui à ce moment-là déclencherait
effectivement une procédure judiciaire
mais je ne peux pas être me semble-t-il
concomitants fait partie sofa sauf
encore une fois est-ce que le
l'entourage soient convaincus de trafic
ce qu'on a essayé de faire plusieurs
reprises et quelquefois on y arrive et
quand même madame danielle michel
vous avez dit que pour être efficace la
lutte contre le dopage doivent être en
cohérence avec l'international bruit est
ce que est ce qu'il y à ousse qu'on a
identifié des des freins de niveau
international qui ralentissent la lutte
contre le dopage en france même la cena
sénatrice
j'ai évoqué un un obstacle c'est celui
du financement des programmes de lutte
antidopage dans des pays qui ne
disposent pas de moyens je crois que le
budget du laborde de la fld de l'ordre
de 7 millions d'euros
je pense pas que les chiffres aient
beaucoup bougé depuis que j'ai quitté le
ministère mais la totalité de l'argent
public destiné à la lutte antidopage et
la préservation des sportifs loi doit
approcher les 20 millions d'euros en
france vous imaginez bien qu'il ya un
certain nombre de pays deux continents
qui ne peuvent pas supporter une telle
une telle dépense donc ça c'est me
semble-t-il
le premier obstacle si nous devons
peut-être envoyer un message
aux différents intervenants dans la
lutte antidopage
je pense que c'est surtout au niveau des
fédérations internationales qu'il faut
l'envoyer et qu'elle développe elle-même
un programme beaucoup plus ambitieux en
matière de contrôle et de mise en place
du passeport biologique comme je le
disais tout à l'heure et certaines
fédérations internationales qui encore
aujourd'hui rechigne un peu à mettre en
place rapidement
ce type d'évolution qui me semblent
indispensables à la qualité de la lutte
antidopage et à la préservation de la
santé des sportifs de haut niveau
voilà me semble t'il plus que les
organisateurs ce que croit vous avez eu
le débat plus que les organisateurs les
organisateurs sont des prestataires de
services
je veux bien qu'on les mette devant un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
mais ils ne sont pas en charge ou où que
ce soit du contrôle et heureusement
d'ailleurs
et heureusement parce qu'à partir du
moment où vous demandez un organisateur
de mettre en place le contrôle
alors là il peut y avoir conflit
d'intérêt il me semble absolument
important de laisser l'organisateur en
dehors de tout ça par contre d'imposer
effectivement un calendrier peut-être
plus contraints aux fédérations
internationales et ça c'est le rôle de
l'agencé mondiale antidopage et
quelquefois quand ces fédérations sont
inclus au programme des jeux olympiques
de et c'est un peu dommage qu'on
n'entende plus aujourd'hui le président
de l'ama alors que dick pound le faisait
régulièrement il commençait à menacer
certaines fédérations de les retirer du
programme olympique si elles
n'appliquent pas rapidement le code
mondial
je pense que c'est dans cette direction
qu'il faut aller merci
nous acheminons vers la fin de notre
rencontre peut-être une ou deux
questions encore la part du rapporteur
qui m'a dit qu'il avait encore une ou
deux questions nous avons et nous allons
aussi continuer à auditionner des
ministres des sports
certains l'ont été avant vous d'autres
ont été vos ou successeur et c'est vrai
qu'il y en a un qui a beaucoup insisté
sur le point que vous venez de soulever
c'est à dire la nécessité d'impliquer
davantage responsabiliser davantage les
organisateurs d événements mais là donc
je vois que vous avez une position
plutôt plutôt divergents clés dessus
simplement il y à un autre ministre des
sports qui nous a fait part des des
pressions auxquelles un ministre des
sports pouvait être soumis dans la lutte
antidopage en particulier lorsqu'il
s'agit d' équipe nationale ou de
compétition internationale organisée sur
le territoire
ce territoire visé par exemple pendant
ces périodes qui ont concerné des
candidatures françaises aux jeux
olympiques en 2008 en 2012
est ce que vous avez connu ce genre
d'intervention et puis tout à l'heure on
vous a senti prêt à faire une mise au
point concernant les relations un peu
chaotique
un peu difficile avec le président
bordry lorsqu'il était à la tête de la
fld et notamment à propos des dossiers
l'an 10 donc on vous laissera intervenir
là dessus merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur
c'est pas une divergence avec mon
collègue et ami david douillet canton
par l'organisateur je crois que le sujet
tourne essentiellement autour du tour de
france s'il ya bien un problème du tour
de france c'est pas le problème de la
hes-so c'est le problème que le tour de
france ne reporte pas la fédération
française de cyclisme que vous savez
mais directement à une série
là c'est un problème est un problème qui
est permanent depuis que l'uci ait
existé que le tour de france existent si
je puis dire et c'est bien
et là c'est là où il faut être je crois
assez content de notre dispositif
français c'est que sur toutes les autres
compétitions tout même si les
fédérations internationales
ce sont elles qui impose le dispositif
en matière de contrôles antidopage
l'organisateur passe par le fils de la
fédération française qui est vous savez
un des principaux interlocuteurs des
fédérations internationales et je vois
mal aujourd'hui l'organisateur seul
pouvoir prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions sans en mettre en
difficulté vis-à-vis de l'union cycliste
internationale pour ne citer qu'elles
donc moi je pense qu'effectivement si
pression il doit y avoir en tout cas et
je le disais tout à l'heure on répond
dans madame à votre question je crois
que c'est essentiellement en direction
des fédérations internationales par le
canal de l' agence mondiale antidopage
et moi je suis très heureux de voir que
banal fourneyron et à nouveau maintenant
au board de au board de l' agence
mondiale antidopage et je suis convaincu
qu'elle fera pas céder les bons messages
est ce que j'ai subi des pressions
aucune aucune je lis bien aucune
par contre qu'il ya eu des
interprétations divergent c'est une
évidence mais ça c'est la loi du genre
quand il s'agit de d'essayer de
confronter deux visions et de culture en
matière antidopage mais je dois le dire
également et j étais mon propos
liminaire il ya eu un avant et un après
code mondial antidopage
la pression pouvait être important des
jeux j'entends ce que vous disais
essentiellement la madame buffet je
comprends parce que les règnes n'est pas
établi vous aviez pour le même produit
trois mois de sanction dans un pays et
deux ans dans un autre pays et mme est
par nature la divergence en matière de
contrôle et de sanction incitent
évidemment à faire des pressions a dit
non mais attendez pourquoi vous mettez
deux ans vous dans votre billet alors
qu'ailleurs c'est trois mois et le code
a beaucoup pacifié finalement les
relations entre les gouvernements
si besoin était et surtout entre les
gouvernements et des fédérations en
imposant des critères de contrôle et des
critères de sanctions qui était
extrêmement cohérent j'ai répondu à vos
questions donc je vais me permettre de
faire cette mise au point puisque
rapporteur m'y incite monsieur le
président à moins que vous ayez
donneront le lait si je vous ai deja que
j'ai fait j'en autres rencontres merci
bien j'ai dit en introduction que
s'engager dans la lutte antidopage et
quelque chose de da c'est violent vous
le savoir les coups bas sont sont réels
ils sont assez fréquents les propos
tenus sont quelquefois inacceptable
mais il ya une chose qui compte en
matière de lutte antidopage soit valable
en france comme partout ailleurs c'est
la réalité des informations et le fait
toujours et encore d'éviter de cole
porter un certain nombre de rumeurs et
de fausses informations
il en va d'ailleurs de comment dirais-je
déjà de la qualité de la lutte
premièrement et deuxièmement il un vrai
aussi de l'honneur des sportifs et de
ceux qui luttent efficacement contre le
dopage donc il faut que ces informations
soient réels et là il faut bien le dire
de ce que j'ai pu lire je sais pas si
c'est exactement ce qui a été dit mais
on est là effectivement dans le domaine
de l'information tronquée qui révèle
donc une mauvaise gestion de
l'information voire un niveau
d'incompétence atteint par ceux qui
colportent ce genre d'information deux
remarques ont été faites sans mutile
monsieur le rapporteur vous me direz si
je me trompe pas simplement sûrement
nice mais précédemment sur la sphère
amstrong en particulier monsieur de ses
hauts risques que nous avons tenues
toujours soutenu de nord soutenu j'ai
d'ailleurs à votre disposition si vous
le souhaitez un échange de courriers en
particulier quand il a fallu qu'ils
s'opposent à lui saisi après avoir livré
à la main à ma demande avec mon
autorisation
les analyses effectuées sur les
substrats du tour de france 99
je vous rappelle pour la première fois
pour la première fois en 2000 monsieur
de ses hauts risques pouvaient détecter
le p ô dans l'uriné et il a donc fait
une recherche
anonyme je le dis bien anonyme sur les
substrats de 99
il a effectivement à selon la détecter
des traces de p o
et il a fourni avec notre autorisation
et à la demande de l'ama les résultats
de ces analyses
anonyme à l'agencé mondiale antidopage
et tout ça a été fait encore une fois en
parfaite intelligence avec le ministère
après que nous ayons évidemment valide
et que tout cela reste est anonyme et je
le rappelle en 2005 puisque ce sont puis
ce que ce sont des faits qui remontent à
le président de l'aef de du cpl des à
l'époque qui n'était pas encore la fld
le président de ducey pelles et n'avait
aucune autorité sur le laboratoire
national du dépistage du dopage donc je
vois mal comment il peut se permettre
d'évoquer effectivement les relations en
tout cas des éléments d'informations
concernant la sphère hameçon quant à la
faire l'an 10 contrairement
au président de l'époque de la fld nous
avons soutenu le laboratoire je rappelle
que le laboratoire a été entre imec
cambriolé informatiquement puisqu'il a
subi une intrusion
à cette époque là on en a remonté la
source tout cela venait des états unis
et il fallait défendre l'honneur du
laboratoire qui était attaquée dans ses
procédures de contrôle
nous l'avons défendue nous voulu avons
d'ailleurs donné les moyens
en tout cas nous avons demandé à la fld
qui donc à cette époque devenait
l'autorité de tutelle du laboratoire de
faire en sorte que monsieur de ces
risques puissent aller défendre son
honneur devant le tribunal
enfin en tout cas la commission
arbitrale américaine pour statuer du cas
de landis dans un premier temps là effet
le dr fusée et suite à notre insistance
est ce que certainement monsieur bordry
appel dépression il a effectivement
financer le voyage d'un représentant de
la fld de du laboratoire aux états unis
pour défendre l'honneur de notre
laboratoire et effectivement il ya une
divergence d'interprétation entre la fld
ministère sur le 40 10 je le reconnais
bien volontiers pas des pressions ce que
je disais tout à l'heure mais une
différence d'interprétation elle est la
suivante et jean conclurait parce
qu'elle est assez symbolique de ce que
doit être la lutte antidopage on avait
deux solutions
on a une solution américaine qui faisait
en sorte que si le l'arbitrage américain
condamnait landis alors cette
condamnation s'appliquait sur tous les
pays et sur toutes les compétitions
la fld en incriminant l'an 10 16 en
sorte que la liste ne pouvait pas faire
des compétitions en france mais tu es
libre de faire les compétitions ailleurs
qu'en france
et nous avons choisi en tout cas moi
j'ai préféré effectivement c'était en
tant que vice-président de l'agencé
antidopage en accord total avec à la
fois du sade à l'organisme de lutte
antidopage américain et l'ama nous avons
préféré en tout cas nous avons souhaité
effectivement que l'arbitrage américain
préval en tout cas soit soit géré avant
l'arbitrage de la fld bien nous en a
pris c'est ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure puisque monsieur landis a été
interdit de toute compétition avant
l'étape du tour de france avant
l'édition du tour de france 2007 et je
crois que si on devait symboliser ce
sera ma conclusion vraiment le progrès
qui a été effectué en matière de lutte
antidopage ces dernières années c'est
bien au travers de cette de ce travail
en relation étroite avec les différents
intervenants et surtout ce qui compte
c'est à dire l'effecacité à la fois des
procédures et des sanctions appliquées
vous l'avez vu monsieur en lice n'est
jamais réapparu dans une compétition
sportive après qu'il ait été condamné
par l'arbitrage américain je me permets
monsieur le ministre vous confirmer que
par rapport aux prélèvements concernant
les tours de france 98 et 99 99
je vous ai parlé que 99 des échantillons
dont il est question en 2005 était
anonyme
bien sûr monsieur deux services à suivre
une procédure ama qui était d'effectuer
un certain nombre de contrôles
totalement anonyme pour aviser
épidémiologique pour savoir à l'époque
en gros quel est à l'état de santé du
peu le ton en 90 j'ai bien dit 99 99
points je ne vous pas que de la
transmission des résultats 81
monsieur de service a utilisé la
procédure classique avec encore une fois
des documents à l'afrique était danone
amis d'anonymiser part dans les flaques
en terre de changer de numéro
les flacons et les substrats d'effectuer
ces contrôles et de fournir ensuite à
l'âme à une liste
de contrôle qui s'avérait entre
guillemets positif au sens où il ils
contenaient des traces de métabolites de
p o
ensuite il a fallu que je crois en fait
pas si vous le l'auditionner mais le
talent d'un journaliste de l'équipe pour
match comme on dit match et les
résultats ceux de qui lui ont été
fournis je ne sais comment de monsieur
de ces auris et le fait qu'il soit allé
à du seuil chercher les fameux seuil que
nous n'avions plus nos qui permettait de
voir effectivement quel était le numéro
qu'elle était le sportif et quelles
étaient les produits incriminés et qui
avait été plus donc
ça c'est pas moi qui peut lire ce que
nous nous avons simplement autorisé le
laboratoire à transmettre à la main le
résultat anonyme des substrats qui
étaient congelés au laboratoire pour 99
je le précise bien tous deux raisons
mais nos rangs ce sont un peu mais les
meilleurs des meilleurs sont restés ces
personnes cherchent
enfin merci beaucoup ce mr pour ce que
vous êtes venu nous dire et bonne
continuation la commission d'une bonne
continuation à vos mandats le ministre
est bonne fin de que pyongyang est merci
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sénatoriale sur le dopage si
vous souhaitez revoir ses auditions
elles sont disponibles en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr bonne fin
de journée à tous